what if I was completely authentic with
my own pain
I stopped with all the [__] and and
stopped with trying to be anything else
other than let me write something that
is very authentically myself
I sat down to write this film about
grief and about loss but also about how
one stands back up
as a writer this is what's gurgling
inside of you and when you sit down and
stare at the blank cursor to see what's
going to come out this is what came out
we all face difficult experiences at
some point in our lives loss grief
disappointment but what if we could use
our creativity to process our emotions
and in turn illustrates that hope help
and healing is possible well today we
explore the art of understanding
accepting and processing emotion with
the incredibly talented actor writer
director and new friend Zach Braff many
of you may know Zach from the hit TV
show Scrubs or perhaps from his seminal
directorial debut Garden State which was
a much celebrated independent film that
Zach wrote directed and starred in but
today we dive into the creative process
behind Zach's newest directorial effort
a good person which is this really
beautiful story about a young woman
whose World crumbles in the wake of
surviving just an unimaginable tragedy
it's a story about grief it's about
addiction forgiveness trust it's about
friendship and most importantly the
messy path to sobriety to becoming whole
which are all themes very close to my
heart we also discuss Zach's own
personal journey in bringing this
particular story to life and the impact
that he hopes it will have on audiences
Zach is an artist in the truest sense of
the word I really love getting to know
him through this conversation and it's
just a privilege to share his wisdom and
experience with you today final note if
you care about independent cinema like I
do then please make a point of going to
the theater this weekend and checking it
out a good person opens Nationwide March
24th how long it remains in the theaters
is kind of up to you so if you enjoy
this conversation and I think you will
let's uh help Zach out a little bit and
make this one a hit and with that here
we go this is me and Zach broth
you run every single day no I've got
like lower back issues right now so I'm
actually bench from running at the
moment doing all these weird exercises
to try to alleviate my back pain but I
might be looking at surgery so I'm a
little hampered which is red Goldstein
you know that actor from um from Ted
lasso who plays uh you know the tough uh
Roy Kent uh-huh do you watch that show a
little bit I'm like one of the few
people that hasn't like going deep on I
directed that's why I'm I'm invested
because I know I know but anyway um
famous biscuit episode yes yeah he I I I
might have lower back issues too and I
saw him at a party and he goes I want
you to read this book uh he goes I'm
someone who's had back surgery and I'm
going to send you a book I want you to
get this book because it's all in your
mind yeah yeah yeah did you read it I've
got a great story about it but finish
your thought but anyway I'm like I'm
literally at this at this get-together
with a [__] back brace on and he hugs
me and he feels it and he goes I've had
surgery I've I've gone down the Wormhole
and you're gonna you're gonna roll your
eyes at me but you should read this book
so I haven't read the book yet but I
ordered the book yeah so it's it's by
this guy I believe it's Paul sarnow is
definitely remember the title but it's
something like uh you know healing back
pain and the thesis of this book is
essentially that uh most not all back
pain but certain types of back pain are
really the result of unhealed emotional
trauma and if you go into that and heal
that you will release whatever it is
that's causing you that pain I believe
the hypothesis it is a good hypothesis I
think there's truth in that and and that
book has been recommended to me so many
times by so many people over the years
and I consistently resisted it so you
don't understand you know you don't
understand this is real and I've got
MRIs and like the whole thing I've tried
all these alternative modalities and
then I was at a birthday party
maybe six months ago
and uh
talking to
um
a PT person and a breath work person who
and they're like we can help you and
like we're having this back and then and
then up walks Toby Maguire and he's like
are you talking about back pain and then
he tells his story of back pain and he
refers this book right and I was like
okay I've been referred this book a
million times but now but I've never
been referred by this book by like an
A-list
Spider-Man is this the voice of God and
I was like all right I'm gonna get this
book and I I like downloaded it on
Audible and I went on a long bike ride
and I listened to the whole thing and I
was like okay it's in my mind and then
the next day I like went out and went
running
um and kind of pushed myself a little
bit more than I should have and I
thought well I'm not hurting myself
because it's all in my mind right and
then my back seized up and I was like in
bed for two days I don't know so well
that book might not be intended for like
Mega marathoners like you but for people
like me who can point to yeah I have had
a lot of emotional trauma and I also
have a horrible back and neck maybe it's
something to look at I don't know that
the book's gonna tell me how to fix it
right I can certainly I can I certainly
have bouts of bad backs after a periods
of of depression or periods of trauma uh
so that's information right that's good
information that's good data yeah you
should read the book I'm gonna it is a
good book it's on my kitchen counter
yeah so now I'm recommending it to you
you know like I had a awkward experiment
with it
um anyway Sunday emergency pods Sunday
afternoon we're here thank you for
coming thank you for doing this thank
you uh it's an auspicious day it is uh
unusual for us to do a podcast on the
weekend on top of that it's daylight
savings today it's also Oscar Sunday I
take it you're not going to the hospital
I'm not going to the Oscars I I I'm
low-key watching it with friends on a
couch yeah have you been in the past
I've never been to the Oscars I've been
to After parties and stuff like that but
I've never had I've never had
um a film that was that was invited in
any way I've been done the Globes and
the Emmys but never never yeah the big
the big dance yeah but but like you
would be like I would imagine you would
be invited right like are you somebody
who's like I'm not going unless I have a
film there I've never been invited yeah
um I I've never I've never had a film
that was included so you're really not
invited unless you're uh there have a
film that's there or you're someone's
date
I got it right well we're here instead
yeah the constellation right
um but we're here because you do have uh
this wonderful new movie coming out
a good person thank you for uh letting
me take a peek at it the other day and
uh I'm excited for you man this is uh
this you know we had texts about it
um this feels like a return to something
that is so authentically you like like
the grown-up Garden State Zach Braff
like exploring complicated emotions
in a way that you know is a story
version of how you're kind of processing
you know things that you went through in
your own life yeah that's very true I
think I went back to
what if I was completely authentic with
my own pain
and that's something that Garden State
very
much was and I had no idea that it would
have the response it had but I was 25
years old when I wrote it
um and I was in a very depressed state
even though a lot of wonderful things
were going on in my life I I just was
quite lost and um and that's kind of
what bubbled up and what came out of me
and now
um I uh during the pandemic
circumstances were such that uh this is
what came out of me and um so I think I
think you're right in both instances I
really I stopped with all the [__]
and and stopped with trying to be
anything else other than For Better or
For Worse let me write something that is
very authentically myself
the impetus really the direct impetus
was these a series of losses that you
experienced most specifically like
you're you had your best friend who was
like living in your guest house right
during covid well the the first impetus
for writing about tragedy and and Trauma
was I lost my my sister had an aneurysm
in 2016.
um
and she she actually survived although
in in the not a fully conscious state in
some
some tiny percentage of herself was
alive uh for two more years
um and my mom and brother in particular
were by her bedside almost every day uh
because they were lived up north and I
would go visit her and she was not
um
it's only a fraction of herself was
there
um then she eventually uh passed and um
soon after my father who was 84 but
uh I I can't help but think that it it
kind of expedited his demise he he died
of cancer
um after
I went into the covid still grieving all
of these things
and then my best friend was living in my
guest house he and his wife and their
newborn baby were uh searching La for
for a home they found a home
they went back to New York uh to collect
their things and literally like the
first day of lockdown
um
uh they were they came back from New
York and he had contracted covet and
this was at the very beginning right
early early nobody knew what the hell
you know is the Mayhem of the beginning
of I think March was of 2020 right uh
he's 41 years old very healthy a
Broadway star
um trying to get his life going as a TV
and film actor and um and he was very
sick and they put him on a ventilator
and he never came off of it So Not only
was I on the front lines of
losing someone who is close to me to
covid but his wife and baby were living
in on my on my property in the guest
house
you know trying to digest this this
horrible thing and and it was it was so
traumatic because we we didn't know if
she had covet or we didn't know
you know it was so we now is back when
we're all like sort of spraying our
groceries in the front line and all that
kind of craziness and so she there's a
lot of fear she'd be sobbing in in a
pile on the on the ground and we and we
were like
can we hug or is it safe to hug her she
she might have been exposed to it
so it was really really uh horrific and
it was in in that headspace uh during
the lockdown that I I sat down to write
this film
um
about grief and about loss but also
about how
how one stands back up after after such
things
yeah it's it's an interesting it's well
for me like I'm not like a film critic
or somebody who has tons of filmmakers
you know on the podcast so I don't know
where the line is like I don't want to
um spoil anything for anybody so maybe
we root it just in in the theme well
there's certain things that are in the
trailer that we can we can yeah yeah I
mean what I found interesting about it
is yes you explore these themes of of
you know uh of grief and loss and
loneliness and despair and and this kind
of very messy road to finding your way
forward to recovery but you do it
through modalities that are very
different from your lived experience
right so there's a choice that you made
like you could have had a more direct
kind of narrative that related more
specifically to the things that you
experienced but you made this decision
to do it through you know somebody who's
who who is you know involved in a car
accident and there are people that die
and and there's you know drugs involved
and Etc which is not related to your
direct experience although the emotional
experience of of that character's
journey I I assume you know kind of
matches up with your own I think so yeah
I think it was the way I was processing
all of these things but I didn't want to
write specifically the story of of my
life I didn't want to write about covid
I didn't want to write about my sister's
aneurysm right but all of that was
you know it's like as a writer I'm sure
you know and other writers can relate
you you have all of this this is what's
gurgling inside of you and when you sit
down and stare at the blank cursor to
see what's going to come out
or a songwriter I imagine would be the
same
this is what came out this story is it
was sort of my
interpretation of all these feelings I
had including
um recovery and and things I'm wrestling
with with my own relationship to
to alcohol and um
all of that stuff became um became a
part of it
um but it's but it's by no means
directly
um my story
yeah and it's it's interesting like that
you know somebody who's who's been in
recovery for a long time like my my kind
of radar for false notes in in movies
and television that kind of grapple with
addiction stories is pretty finely tuned
right and and even we were talking and
you're like
it'll be interesting to get my feedback
on that because usually people who tell
a story in that in that subculture are
people that have experience you know be
participating in that right which is
which is not you which you know led me
to think well maybe you know he's going
to get it wrong because so often it is
like you know off Note
um but in watching the film and this is
the honest truth like I was surprised
that you were able to create such
fidelity
because that is typically you know
something that only somebody who has
direct experience with that world would
be able to accomplish and I know you had
you know experts or Consultants or
whatever helping you with that but
that's a very hard thing to do and I
think it's it it's
um
for me the the kind of Cinema verite of
it all or or the kind of honesty comes
through in the messiness of it like
usually the the the story arc is
somebody has a hard time they're going
through something they hit bottom they
end up in the rooms of recovery and then
the movie ends are like that's the end
of the story whereas in this narrative
it's it's it's very up and down right
that's not the end of the story and I
think that's much more true to reality
like how difficult and non-linear the
whole thing is well thank you I have to
say uh that means so much to me coming
from you and I was very nervous to show
you I did of course have Consultants I
did not want to
uh do anything that someone in the
community would go that's not real I
asked a lot of questions I have friends
in in in AAA I have a I I had someone
who's uh sort of a recovery expert who
was on set anytime we dealt with that
stuff but when I was showing you the
film I was like so nervous that that
that not just of course you know it
isn't hard to get the details of what an
AAA meeting is like or or or perhaps but
I really just wanted to honor that
community and in this film it saves uh
the character played by Florence Pugh's
life and the character played by Morgan
Freeman's life so
um I wanted to honor the community so
when you when you when you had that
reaction I was relieved and happy yeah
yeah it's not an easy it's not an easy
thing uh to accomplish uh of course you
you have this incredible uh you know Ace
in the hand with Florence because she's
just a genius yeah I mean her
she what she is able to do is is so like
Beyond like you know the the the
abilities of of of mere mortals like it
really is not of this world like it's
incredible she's not of this world I
really believe how does she do that and
it's completely with her face or just
with the most subtle thing the honesty
and the pathos is unbelievable with her
I'll I'll make it one more step
miraculous for you she has never
attended a single class in her entire
life she's never spoken to a acting
coach it is one thousand percent
god-given natural Talent
I'm not biased in saying she's one of
the finest actors in the world
everyone's lining up from Chris Nolan to
denivel enough to ariaster to you name
it they're all in a line to try and work
with her
and I wrote this for you know we we were
it's no secret obviously we were
partners and she she was with me through
this pandemic we were in lockdown
together she was she was she's an
amazing chef and she was making Amanda
pizzas and in our little mini pizza oven
and bringing them down to her we were on
the front lines of this experience
together we went through lockdown and
and and the death of our friend together
um and so I wrote this with her and with
her in mind
um
because I I wanted to to write something
for her because she's brilliant yeah
well she knocks it out of the park
um not surprisingly and I really do
think that she is the greatest of her
generation yeah you know she is here a
parent uh to Meryl Streep so many ways
like the nobody nobody can do what she
can do and so you watch her you're like
how is she doing and it's so exciting
for the it's so exciting I gotta say
it's so exciting for the acting
Community because we
there's plenty of people that are very
fine actors I I think I'm a decent actor
I can I I think I do a good job but we
actors whether it's me or or or Meryl
Streep
are taking this woman aside and being
like holy [__] you are [__]
incredible so what is that like what is
her process
it's god-given man there's there's
nothing she just channels it I mean I'm
not saying she doesn't do work she she
of course she she works on the character
she spoke with um
uh in in this in this film our character
has an opioid addiction and she spoke
and and met with a woman who recovered
from a bad opioid addiction and talked
about what withdrawal was like what
you know she sort of interviewed her and
talked about please tell me anything and
everything she watched videos she does
her research don't get me wrong but
um
it's it's it's it's it's I don't know
what to say other than it's just a a
natural ability that's that's um out of
this world and you is the director like
what is your interface with her in terms
of like how your how you're you know
directing her how you're nudging her to
get the performance out of her that that
you want or need or do you just get out
of the way I think with with people like
her and Morgan you just don't get in the
way
um
the way I think of it is
as an actor you know we shoot everything
out of order as you know and so an actor
is so focused in them a good actor a
great actor is so focused in the moment
in the scene just like you and I are
talking here right now we are our job is
to ignore that there's cameras ignore
that there's lights look at each other
and be present and the best instruction
you can ever give a young actor is to
genuinely listen
because if I'm genuinely listening to
you rich I am so in the moment and
present my brain is listening to you
it's like a meditation I'm not thinking
of the moving camera I'm not thinking of
the guy whispering in his walkie-talkie
I'm with you
and so they're in that moment my job as
the Director is to look at the macro of
the whole film
I need to go
I wonder if Morgan is a little bit angry
in the sequence of their evolution of
their relationship
maybe I should and it's always a
question with a genius like that you're
like do you think we should try one we
are not as angry here because we're
gonna go ABCDEFG
and what do you think
and normally someone like them will be
like that's smart let's let's try one
like that um other times they'll be like
no no I'm really feeling this because of
because of these reasons and you go
great great keep going so I'm mostly
staying out of the way but I'm shaping
it because like the conductor of an
orchestra I have to see the whole piece
you're not going think of it like
Florence Pugh is like the best first
violinist in the world
and I'm the conductor I can't play
violin like that but I do know that at
certain moments she needs to be a little
quieter so I can hear the oboe right do
you know what I mean yeah yeah and
that's what my job is as a filmmaker
working with with actors of that level
yeah having that Global awareness where
this puzzle piece fits in the broader
picture of the movie and making sure
that it's simpatico in the flow and
keeping the tone and keeping the tone
cohesive that's really important because
a movie like this which I should I
should say off the bat because we've
only talked about the heavy stuff also
has a lot of humor in it so
it's very imperative that the director
is also really in control of the tone
what movie are we all making we have to
make sure we're making the same movie
so there's other moments where you can
go
that's a bit too broad for a humorous
moment for this movie or sometimes you
try them
and then go in the edit I gotta see that
might that might not fit in this film
when I start to really strip away all
the all the pieces of clay and find out
what this movie is that might be too
broad this might be too modeling you
know so you're you're kind of the you're
the one in charge of the tone of the
thing yeah yeah and that I feel like
there is a bit of a tone Arc in this
movie because it kind of opens with
Morgan Freeman's voice over and that
he's you know the voice of America it's
like that soothing voice and there's
train sets and you're you're thinking oh
this is there's something you know
perhaps
um very homey or or potentially you know
on the negative side maybe even too
sappy and then the movie kind of
develops into this you know kind of
Darker terrain that it's exploring but
then Florence Pew's mom is Mount is
Molly Shannon who can go super broad
right like that could get too nutty yeah
like if you're not making sure that
that's properly California
that's the perfect articulation of what
my job is as a filmmaker is to make sure
we're all making the same movie yeah
yeah like that somebody else is in
another movie yeah well that happens all
the time the whole thing yeah you'll see
that you know once you you sometimes the
audience won't won't even know how to
articulate it necessarily like that but
they'll go why are these scenes off it's
because that character is in a different
film there's there's things I've Loved
but every time there's a scene with X
character I go oh this is this person's
in a different piece right and it it
pulls me it alienates me every single
time and that's the job of the director
to make sure to avoid that or I think so
everyone's on the same I think so and
and by the way people might love it it
might just be my own personal uh uh
squirm that I go oh my goodness this
would be so much better if that
character was in the same tone as the
rest of this yeah
there's something about this movie also
that that feels a little bit kind of out
of time given the current kind of state
of Hollywood like this is a very
traditional Indie movie in the Sundance
tradition you made it with killer films
right like the you know Premiere
production company for this type of
movie and in the era in which you came
up in the Garden State times it was all
about Sundance like that was like the
Zeitgeist of the culture and like
launching an independent film into
mainstream awareness
um and and there you know that was
something
that uh you know the culture kind of
invested in right that's a lot of energy
around that now Hollywood is a very
different place completely different and
it changes it changes every year it's
different from last year it's like I
mean my wife enjoy we went to go to the
movies the other day and we're like What
can we see and we're like these are the
options like 80 for Brady like what are
we gonna you know like what it is I want
to go to the movies I want to be excited
to go to the movies there was nothing
exciting well I made a movie for you yes
I know I'm getting to my point which is
that it has become rarer and rarer that
there is you know mature adult fare that
deals with uh you know themes that you
know appeal to someone like myself
um that find their way into the movie
theaters it's either Marvel DC giant
Event Event picks or the occasional you
know outlier like everything everywhere
all at once yeah but that's still that's
still visual spectacle so I would say it
falls into sure visual spectacle and
horror Horror's big still yeah Horrors
predictable to yeah because but a movie
like yours these movies don't end up in
the movie theater like it's it's amazing
that you figured out a way to get this
movie in the movie theater that's why
I'm praying that people go how did that
happen that's a great question how did
it happen it happened because MGM so
believed in the film that they said they
were going to give it a theatrical
release
now mind you this film was we shot in
the fall of 2021 it was it was ready to
come out uh end of 2022 but Florence had
two other high-profile films and it was
a bit crowded of a Marketplace so uh MGM
held it until uh this spring March 24th
um so
um in the meantime I was the the company
was purchased by Amazon right
and so in my head I'm terrified I'm
going to just put it right did I lose my
mind you know if you go if I say to
other filmmakers I have a theatrical
release they're like what
yeah to your point it's very rare that
these films even get a theatrical
release anymore
um but I and so I was nervous that
Amazon would would just put it on
streaming um but they believe in it too
so um I think the response has been so
so positive that
um they're gonna give it um they're
gonna give it a run
um it'll be on 500 screens on on on the
first weekend which friend Indie is is
substantial and then it's all about how
it performs opening weekend and that
will dictate of course
every filmmaker's uh future uh I know
you work your butt off for so many
gears and Blood Sweat and Tears and it
all uh really comes down to if people
show up the first weekend sure and and
those numbers come in like Friday night
right like there's an algorithm that
predicts based upon uh the numbers on
Friday night how it's gonna do right and
sometimes they'll surpass those numbers
like Creed really surpassed it's it's
it's the algorithm but yeah based on all
the the decades and Decades of data they
have although that should mostly be
thrown out the window post covered
because all bets are off now post
covered no one knows what's happening
but but traditionally there's an
algorithm that says based on what's
Happening you know noon on Friday we can
predict what the weekend will be but
sometimes they're off you know they were
way off on Creed Creed did like 20
million dollars more than they thought
and so how do you
um balance
your relationship to you know the
creative act of of of of making
something and shipping it to use Seth
godin's term like you're putting this
thing out out into the world which you
should be very proud of like it's
beautifully rendered and it's you know
exquisitely performed and all of that
like that exists you know as this kind
of music box thing and then there's the
Commerce piece and the the public
response to it and all the kind of you
know running around promoting it kind of
stuff that you have to do the external
uh you know noise around it like how do
you maintain your sanity in the way I
don't know I don't know I don't know man
um I uh you're right though and I've
heard you speak about this with other
people and I really appreciated your
perspective on it because and I think we
it was maybe your episode was Seth one
of your episodes with Seth Godin that I
that I maybe I'm thinking of but yeah
that that difference between
being so proud of something and yes this
is like your book this is 100
authentically me
and I'm I I'm now it's now it's up to
the universe to decide it's fate whether
people go to the theaters whether people
uh respond to it or not uh but how do
you still hold on to good or bad that
I'm proud of this thing that I put all
of my my myself into that is that is
very tricky and hard I don't really know
the answer
um do you get caught up in looking at
the reviews and peeking and stuff that
maybe you feel like yeah maybe I
shouldn't look at that or well I got off
Twitter thanks to you uh which was I
mean I still no it was your conversation
with Seth actually you have no idea how
much you really
um
and I mean this in all sincerity how
much how what a positive impact this
podcast has had on me and I really want
to thank you and and I'll probably bring
it up a few times as we chat but one of
them was Seth Godin saying I have no
interest in reading people day trading
their emotions
and that really really landed hard with
me
because I had a very unhealthy
relationship with with constantly
reading Twitter and I don't mean just
stuff that was about me I just mean the
the negativity that is the town of
Twitter yeah and I was obsessed with
being in that town
and I'm someone who battles depression
and anxiety and like I shouldn't be in
that town I'm too sensitive for that
town like if it was a place I wouldn't
go there
so I I still look I'll of course um
say like hey here's my trailer but I
don't obsessively read uh Twitter
anymore yeah
um in terms of reviews I don't go down
the rabbit hole and read all reviews as
a producer on the movie and as a partner
to all to to MGM and and these companies
I'll of course
know the gist I'll know the tone the
tenor of of the response
um but I don't I won't obsessively go
down and read everything I don't I don't
I don't know did you do that with your
book I I don't I don't yeah but that was
a while ago like now I have a very
different
uh relationship with all of that
um at the beginning I was very caught up
in all of that and now you know I I
really work hard to create a buffer
between myself and all of that noise and
I don't get caught up in the
conversations and I unfollowed everybody
on Twitter so I still have a Twitter
account and like yourself like I'll post
stuff that's interesting or my own stuff
but I don't go and and you know scroll
through like what people say about me or
what everybody's saying about the
subject of the like the culture War
subject of the moment or any of that
that's the stuff that really people day
trading their emotions
of course reading something negative
about myself on Twitter was not good for
my extraordinarily sensitive brain but
I'm not even really speaking about that
I'm just talking about the tenor of the
conversation
I just think was really really really
bad for my psyche and another thing I
got from you
I really should be your publicist was I
forgot the name of the author but the
chaos machine
uh Max Fisher that completely I hope
you're I hope your listeners and viewers
get that book because I want to resell
that book to you because I got it off
your podcast and that completely changed
my relationship with social media yeah I
really needed to hear those words and um
I I I I I'm I'm not on I'm a little bit
on uh Instagram because I do enjoy
pictures of things and but I'm but I'm
not on Facebook I'm not on Twitter I'm
not on YouTube obsessively I I that book
was transformational for me yeah he's uh
he's doing he's doing God's work he
really is and I wish more people knew
about it I I found it on your podcast
but I was like I'm just gonna be this
guy's publicist and talk about it
everywhere I go I I'm gonna get I'm
gonna give everyone the book for the
holidays
um I'm sure you're happy to hear that I
don't even have kids but as a parent
yeah I feel like every parent should
read that book because it is insane what
these corporations are are doing to our
minds let alone kids Minds agreed 100
and as a sensitive creative person
um part of your job is to protect that
sensitivity like you have to be kind of
in touch with your you know Emotional
Self and be able to kind of Channel like
what it is that you're feeling and
experiencing and all of that noise uh is
either like the best case is it's a
distraction the worst case is it's it
starts to you know tamper down that
voice or if you feel like you don't you
can't express yourself authentically and
and and honestly and that's antithetical
to like
everything that you need to be about to
do what it is that you do exactly or
even worse Rich you start trying to
chase what you think
people want you to be
you start trying to chase
um creating something that is not in any
way authentically you but is something
you think will be better received by a
studio by an audience bias buy a movie
theater Chain by a Critic
um that's not gonna be good that's like
a band trying to write a Hit album for
the charts
um odds are
um I mean obviously there's there's
certain pop stars that have it dialed uh
they're all written in Stockholm and
they talk about an algorithm for for
creating a hit but um
if you're trying to do
something uh that is personal
like your book or like my films
um trying to to to to to to mold them
into something that that is not you that
is not honest that is not authentic is
going to be a piece of [__] because it's
it's just a mess of something that it's
it's it's like something AI created that
doesn't make any sense yeah because
you're you're so afraid of of the cackle
of the Twitter community that you're
watering down your voice to make it
non-offensive or to make sure that
you're adhering to a certain set of
talking points right that you know will
be approved of by you know the community
you know the online but that's
impossible that's not something that's
terrible that's like the worst but it's
also it's not it's not something you
could ever succeed in doing is pleasing
everybody I think I
um
I think that's another golden thing I
got from you was that I read the tribes
and talking about like find your your
people and speak to them find people
that feel like I do and obviously uh you
and I think alike because I love your
podcast and you liked my movie so find
people love like minds and and who
appreciate what you have to say and make
something for them yeah don't try and
I'm I'm not trying to make a film for
everyone you couldn't
I couldn't
um I don't wouldn't know how yeah we all
have a band we were absolutely love that
some people say they hate sure right
it's like that I mean I I'm so glad that
Coldplay exists Coldplay is one of my
favorite bands people have horror
Coldplay I I like I go to the I go to
the concerts and the stadiums and song
that's funny uh my friend Toby Morse
who's who's been on the podcast before
is like this hardcore like punk rocker
straight edge you know fully covered in
tats and comes from that kind of like
DIY you know community of you know it's
not about the money or whatever but he's
like a super emo bleeding heart for like
Coldplay like he just loves talking
about Coldplay yeah which is
antithetical to like this image of this
like super tatted up guy you know but
it's like there's something beautiful
about that and and it's it's something
that we talked about earlier which is
that
and this goes to kind of the discourse
on social media which is that
prioritizes or favors like cynicism and
irony and negativity and judgment and
scoring points for taking people down a
peg when in truth like earnestness and
enthusiasm and like being a fan of
something and not worrying about whether
it's cool and just being confident in
your own voice and expressing what you
love uh you know the algorithm doesn't
favor that no it might not be approved
of or considered cool in like our
current environment but honestly like
that's the stock and trade of you know
the kind of person that I want to be
around and the artist that I respect
well that's why I'm drawn to your show
because for me what you're putting out
there on the internet is positivity and
curiosity and the desire to learn and
the desire to grow and the desire to be
a better person
um it's the antithesis of what I think
is the tenor of so much of the internet
which is who can outsnark whom and
um I'm trying to turn that some of that
off in my life and and and that that
chaos machine book was like the perfect
articulation of why
um and and and and and and find
um things that are that will help me be
a a Kinder better more interested person
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going with each of
them on my podcast to elucidate the best
of what they have to offer and to
sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
the podcast is not the only medium by
which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the Rich Roll
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table and volume 2
follows in that tradition by showcasing
even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with
interview excerpts essays and stunning
photography making for an Exquisite
companion to the first volume or a
satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
so I I take it on some level that the
process of like writing this movie
provided some kind of therapeutic outlet
for the confusing you know emotions that
you were experiencing the grief of you
know your friend and your sister and
your dad and all of that and covet and
and all of that but you know what is the
connection between like your own mental
health journey and and the kind of
creative Outlet of like writing and
directing stories that help you kind of
make sense of of these things
I've I've really just been battling
um I battled depression and anxiety my
whole life and I I I had OCD pretty bad
as a child
and um
I think I found writing and Performing
as a way of um of dealing with that
particular humor
um
um making people laugh was a high for me
I didn't play sports at all I had no I
had no connection to sports I didn't
know how to make friends so I became
because I was a funny kid I became a
Class Clown and that's how I made
friends and then when I was around 13
years old my you know I lived in the
east coast in Jersey and well Sleepaway
Camp was very popular
and um
a lot of the kids would go to a
traditional C Boy camp that was about
sports and I I didn't I didn't shine and
I and I felt alienated and I was like
what's wrong with me
I love performing and my my parents
found this theater camp for me that was
called Stage Door Manor and I went there
and it was like epiphanous it was Utopia
it was uh it was a place where everyone
was a performer and everyone was like me
and I didn't know that there were other
kids that many kids out there like me so
just from an early age the way I would
manage anxiety and and depression
um was
um creating art whether it was as a
performer or as a or as a writer
um I have a very early memory of of
being in fifth grade and and the teacher
said who's gonna we had to write an
essay and who's gonna get up in front of
the class and read their essay and I did
and I had written other kids in the
class into the essay and made a very
funny essay but the protagonists were
kids in the class and I got up there and
they were belly laughing as I read it
and I remember clocking the teacher in
the back of the classroom holding her
stomach and laughing and I thought this
is probably the highest high I've had in
my life so far yeah
is there any chance this is a career
one's career yeah
um so that's a long-winded way of saying
um that's why I became a writer and a
filmmaker was a way of
um was a way of trying to find shared um
Community with these feelings that I
have and the answer your other question
about is is it cathartic it's most
cathartic when I finally watch it with
an audience and I see their reaction
when they laugh at the right moment when
they swipe a tear at the right moment
when their pin drops silent at the right
moment that's when I feel like
oh I'm not alone in these emotions it's
an antidote to loneliness yeah you're
these emotions that I'm feeling are are
collected absolutely yeah absolutely
that's the best yeah that's better said
than I could have said it it's an
antidote to loneliness yeah
um so you went to you went to like a
public high school in New Jersey but
then you have this summer camp because
your dad was like a gregarious
charismatic guy yeah he was a traveler
theater and that was he was a trial
attorney and he was actually the
original thing was he was a travel
attorney Who Loved theater so he would
we we we were 45 minutes from the city
in Jersey from from Manhattan so we
would go see and he was a lawyer so he
could afford uh I was very lucky he
could afford to bring us to the theater
and I loved musicals as a kid and he
loved them and then he got into
Community Theater you know he would be
the star of the local play because he
was so charming and and and a very good
actor I mean he could have been an actor
um
and and that's kind of was you know
another reason I got my that's how I
ended up at theater campus because he
was wetting my palette with the local
theater and with Broadway
and um
you know that's how it all began and
that was kind of the theater camp that
you went to was like a legit yeah it's
the real Primo Theater Camp right yeah
he came out like some other names came
out well Natalie Portman and Robert
Downey Jr and uh just a few
there's lots Josh Charles uh Mandy Moore
there there's there's some big big names
and by the way are tons that are working
actors who aren't famous yeah a ton of
theater and and name people you see all
the time but you might not know their
name I mean you know if you were a young
kid and you
wanted to pursue this this is where you
went this wasn't this wasn't just as my
father said uh kind of with a little bit
of a laugh he said I guess you don't
need to bring a mitt yeah right but
these are your people like you realize
early on immediately like oh this is my
Lane this is my community I relate to
these people
um I can be you know I can like sort of
stand out here and like be myself and I
don't have to wear the mask that I feel
like absolutely
when it was time to leave I really I was
I really I really can't express to you
how much it felt like
going to a Utopia for six weeks and then
being pulled out to go back to what I
dreaded
um
so it was traumatic in a weird way
because I I had found
what I thought was Heaven on Earth
but there's something really amazing
rare and beautiful about discovering at
an early age like what it is that you
wanted yeah like that that is something
that you know is not
it's not a normal experience like most
people I feel like you know the pressure
that's on you know the typical 18 year
old when they head off to college or
whatever they're supposed to you know
know what they want to do with their
life like most people don't like that
rare occasion where you're like oh this
is the thing that I'm gonna be doing you
know it's like there's something amazing
about I feel very lucky about that and I
know that people struggle for you know
for years to find out what they're
calling is I I do feel very lucky that I
knew it at such a young age yeah I
figure I'm I think I'm starting to
figure it out I think you've got a
couple of things you're really good at
man it was at least I don't know mid-40s
before I figured it out but anyway
um
and I think people you know they know
you from Scrubs they know you from
Garden State they'll know you even more
from this movie and and and you've done
you know lots of things over the years
uh but you you know you you kind of like
you know hit it hard early on yeah like
your early years like I feel like that's
kind of an underreported aspect of your
career like yeah I had beginners getting
cast in like a Woody Allen movie when
you were like 18 and then also the
public like you know you being you doing
Shakespeare at the public when you were
how old were you then so I my very first
part I got 14 was a pilot for CBS that
didn't get picked up
um and then I kind of that was the Bruce
Paltrow yeah Bruce Paltrow who created
um scene elsewhere um and it was
gwyneth's father and it was her first
part too
um she was a stunning
17 year old and I was sort of a nerdy 14
year old and she played the beautiful
cheerleader and I played the nerdy
freshman it was about a public school
same year 902 Bibles 90210 came out I
was Bruce Paltrow sort of gritty answer
to 902. this is gonna be the dark side
right by the way the show couldn't even
get picked up today and this was this is
when I was 14 years old it was really
gritty it was bold as hell maybe I'm
streaming I don't know
but um it didn't go anywhere
um it was too R-rated for for CBS
certainly and and then Mike you know I
auditioned I auditioned for lots of
things and then it wasn't until I was
18.
I had gotten in Northwestern to go to
film school and right right before I was
about to go I got cast in Manhattan
murder mystery Woody Allen's film with
uh don Keaton my my first scene in a
movie is is I'm only in one scene in the
movie but my scene partners are Woody
Allen Diane Keaton and Angelica Houston
it's insane and I'm 18 years old and I'm
playing and you were kind of raised on
Woody Allen yeah I mean now now
talk about Woody Allen but I but I do
have to say the truth which is uh uh
without glorifying Woody Allen the truth
is that I was raised on Woody Allen my
father he was my father's favorite
um these you know he was speaking to uh
to my parents they loved it he was their
target demo and so all of those films
were very
um influential in my in my life and then
there I was playing you know Annie Hall
was their favorite movie and there I was
playing Diane Keaton and Woody Allen's
son it was it was really a surreal
moment
and then I sort of thought like well do
I you know this is a big thing do I stay
with this and and not go off to
Northwestern and study film and
um but then I I chose that I said I want
to go I want to really learn how to make
movies and so that's what I did that
took a lot of Courage I think I think
most people probably would have thought
hey I'm on my way like why should I get
off this train I might not be able to
get back on in New York at the time and
we're talking about 93
um being an 18 year old who had just
landed the part of Winnie Allen dying
Keaton's son that was a huge moment
right and I did not I did not passed in
a Woody Allen movie at that time you're
sort of being anointed yes you you're
anointed and then
um and then
and then I I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't ride that wave at all I just
disappeared right um and then I came
back
um after Northwestern and I had a
wonderful Shakespeare teacher um I was
in film school but I talked my way in
acting class Northwestern at the time
separated the the two schools but I
talked about an acting class and I had a
wonderful uh acting teacher and one of
the things he really
introduced me to and explained to me and
gave me the distinctions for was
Shakespeare
and I understood it for the first time
in my life through this incredible
Professor named David Downes
and the very first
thing I got out of Northwestern was uh
in a production of Macbeth starring Alec
Baldwin Angela Bassett Lieb Schreiber
Michael C Hall
um yeah some others
um uh Jason Butler Harner
um and and other incredible New York
theater actors directed by George C
Wolfe who's one of the preeminent
theater directors in New York in a 300
seat house uh at the public theater
um so that was my first job out of
college
bananas and it was crazy and I and I and
I and I had a front row seat to watch
these incredible actors particularly we
have Schreiber who who I will say and I
don't you know those who know New York
theater he's probably the dude he's the
finest new I I believe he's probably the
finest American uh Shakespeare
Shakespearean actor than there is so I
got right out of school and and I don't
mean to diminish anybody else but liab
is particularly gifted I got to have a
front row seat watching we have
Schreiber do Shakespeare and uh that was
that was like life changing and that was
like grad school right I would imagine
also terrifying absolutely he's a pretty
intimidating yeah presence he is and I
was playing two parts uh young Seward
and fleons and flions is is Banquo Leo's
Leo's character's son so I was I was in
awe of him but also uh
but definitely certainly intimidated by
him because he's he's a very strong
presence yeah so you go to Northwestern
to study filmmaking you come out and
you're doing stage acting and you have
all these acting opportunities that are
not necessarily filmmaking opportunities
but the world is kind of like opening up
to you pretty quickly and and not for
nothing like Northwestern like
incredible program I mean who so you
must have been like that era
was like was Seth Meyers yeah it was um
was there Richie Keane do you know
Richard yeah how do you know Richie Kim
yeah one of my great buddies I've like
we could talk about that later but um
lots of people
um Catherine Hahn who's an incredible
actress
um
um and really gaining traction there
were so many really really talented
people and again people that are working
and are brilliant but not necessarily a
household name yeah yeah
um and then how long so at some point
you find your way to Los Angeles though
like how does that happen so it was
funny I was I was in New York I was this
is the height of the music video era
right so I mean this is 1998. the Fuji's
made a video for like seven million
dollars it was like it was like the day
this is the era you know this is like
Spice Girls Mariah Carey this is like
the apex of the music video time people
were spending a fortune I was peeing on
those because I didn't want to take
features as a PA because that would lock
me up and not let me be free to audition
so a PA on a commercial was kind of the
perfect or or music video was a perfect
job for me because I could
do three four days make a little bit of
money and then be free to go on
auditions so that was kind of my my my
system and then I got a little then I
finally got an indie called the um uh
you can count on me that went to
Sundance that was like a big break and
then I got another one called the broken
hearts club which was Greg berlani's
very first uh film and then that went to
sundown so I went to Sundance two years
in a row so I was kind of starting to
get momentum with Timothy oliphon yeah
yeah Timothy oliphon um uh Billy Porter
uh Dean Kane
um
all sorts of wonderful actors
and um and then I I was waiting but I
came out here I had no money I followed
a girl out I used the I was dating a
young woman and I I sort of used that as
a um as the as the impetus but the truth
was I knew this was back in the day
where if you were auditioning in New
York they were fedexing a VHS tape right
that's how you were trying to compete
now if you're the director of a movie
rich and I come in here to audition
we're gonna shoot the [__] a little bit
we're gonna get to know each other we're
gonna have a little bit of a bond and
then I'm gonna launch into my audition
and then you're gonna be able to say I
like that can you try it bring it down a
little bit and give me some notes and
then we're gonna go again now that's
that's how the actors in La were
auditioning then you'd go home and you'd
have a stack of 40 VHS tapes that have
been sent from all over the country
you're gonna barely watch them you're
gonna fast forward them so I knew that
if I was gonna seriously compete I had
to come out to LA
so I did
um my parents loan me five thousand
dollars to buy a car I bought a Nissan
240SX manual
um and uh I got a job at a French
Vietnamese restaurant which was um
called look Colonial it's it's no longer
there but it was a it was in Beverly
Hills at the corner of uh I know well
Beverly and Robertson yes that place had
a moment oh did it I was at the spot I
was there so you were a waiter there I
was a waiter there it's now a Leica
store which is bizarre because I like a
store but two thousand that's that's
like 2002 like that around two it
eventually closed down because it was
meant to be a restaurant but it became
such a hot spot it was it was it was
basically a nightclub that the
neighborhood said this is not what we
give a permit for and it was also I
don't know if you know this well you
work there
um but it was kind of it became like a
like a sober hangout at night
um there was one night was it like
Monday night was the night and like we
were would all go and hang out at La
Colonial yeah I knew that like at 2000.
I threw a party there we served a lot of
coffee I know yeah
it was cool like that was the scene
there was this I'm gonna blow your mind
right now you ready so I had to wear a
tunic and
um the opening sequence of Garden State
where my character is working at a
French Vietnamese restaurant is all
inspired by my experience working at
local yeah I think I knew that yeah yeah
it's true no no now that yeah no it's
yeah that's right that's right yeah
that's wild man that's wild so so
um things had stalled a bit and I and I
was a waiter and I was I was happy to be
making
um money as a waiter but I was not
having any traction all the traction I
had had in New York was gone
and I was just I couldn't get arrested
here
and um
I started to get really insecure about
it maybe I came out here too fast maybe
I I should go back to New York where I
had momentum I was doubting everything
and my agent said you're panicking Don't
Panic uh go through one more pilot
season this is back in the day when when
auditioning for Pilots was actually the
beginning of the year it was like
January to April was pilot season
and um
and I and I did in my first audition um
of that pilot season was for scrubs
it's amazing
little did you know that that would
go on for how many years nine years yeah
yeah
I mean huge show uh and and you know and
thinking about that like in thinking
about your career as like an independent
writer director and also as like a
network television
actor you've forged your career along
two kind of traditional paths like one
you become an actor in like a big
Network sitcom and it's all about
syndication like after a certain number
of episodes or whatever like it just
becomes like you know Financial you know
windfall right that allows you to the
opportunity to like do whatever you want
um that's kind of like no longer I guess
maybe does syndication even still exists
not really no not a nutritional sense no
and then the idea of like being an
independent filmmaker and going to
Sundance and Like Making a Splash and
becoming the new hot thing I guess like
I mean Sundance is still there it's not
what it used to be so everything's kind
of shifted is not what it was and what
we're doing like so when you're there 94
98 like when you know my early years as
an actor 99 in 2000 but then in it in
its prime for Garden State in 2004 I'm
leave
and that was still the era of like
Sunday that was like there was like a
bidding war yeah and it was um I'm I'm
sorry to mention another controversial
name but at the time your your fantasy
which you read about in all the books
was that your cell phone would ring and
it would be Harvey Weinstein
um and he wanted your movies all about
Miramax and then you know it was you
know I had been reading these books like
you know you're a success when your
phone rings and it's Harvey Weinstein
and they want you and that's what
happened to me
um
uh they released it uh internationally
and and Fox Searchlight released it uh
domestically
um but that was the very first
screenplay I ever I I had ever written
and um
when I got scrubs I thought I was so
thrilled obviously but then I one of my
my second thought was
oh this is gonna help me get my movie
made uh-huh
that's the Instinct of a real filmmaker
though that's yeah it's funny I look
back now I I say I I think I I saw
pictures I sent my DP uh from the movie
who's now becoming the oscar-nominated
uh cinematographer Larry Sure Shot The
Joker and a zillion other things but
he's a brilliant guy he shot Garden
State and I found an old picture of us
and I sent it to him and he goes we were
so young and I said we didn't know we
didn't know
because I had such hotspa I didn't I
didn't
I wasn't I didn't I didn't know so much
that I was that I just had so much drive
I was like I'm gonna get this made yeah
I didn't I didn't know that not getting
it 25 26 yeah
when Garden State happened yeah
so you're in this high profile sitcom
you make you write your first screenplay
you make this movie you make it with
Natalie Portman it's a huge success
everyone's talking about it like that's
vertigo inducing for you know a young
man right like how did you process all
of that success
um
I think it takes time it takes looking
back on it just just to see wow what a
crazy time
um it was definitely
um
a whirlwind
um and
um it was it was I I think I instantly
had a terror of trying to duplicate it
right then then it's like how am I ever
gonna top this how am I going to top it
and then
and then you're sort of chasing it
because
I don't it was lightning in a bottle I
don't know how you know it's the classic
sophomore album thing right or sophomore
book or sophomore movie
where it's you know people are like
you're like it's like a band will
release an album and and it's time to
write the software out they spent their
whole life writing the first album right
um my first screenplay was I didn't
spend my whole life writing it but it
was certainly everything I'd been
brainstorming on since I'd gone to film
school and and wanted and dreamed of
creating
and then it was like oh I always admire
Damien chazelle uh
because Whiplash was a huge hit and then
he had he had a bunch of other things
locked and loaded yeah and I didn't I I
was so I took work as an actor in films
that that I'm that some were good some
were bad
um
there was interested in me directing
huge things but I but I was also keep in
mind I was also doing the show for yeah
I was contractually obligated to keep
doing the show for a very long time this
was any of these other things could only
happen during your briefly though yeah
so I would sometimes once I set up a
movie I once set up a movie that I had
adapted from a Danish film I loved and
it was literally
uh Sean Penn was attached to star in it
and it was all about to happen and and
then if we didn't start by a certain
date we couldn't make the movie because
I had to go back to Scrubs and you know
it's very very hard to to to to get
anything made and of course we didn't
hit the date and the whole thing fell
apart right so um I had years of sort of
um
feeling like I [__] everything up
because I I didn't I it was such a it
was such a beginner's luck kind of
situation where I didn't really know how
to recapture it mm-hmm
um and
and also I was it was very hard for me
to write because I was I I maybe you
might feel that way if you've written I
think I've heard you say this on the
podcast that when you've had such a
successful book you're like how do I you
get blocked yeah how do I I don't know I
don't know how to begin to try and top
that I didn't think anyone was going to
see this [__] movie I thought my
parents and like the temple choir would
go
yeah and if he comes this thing you
become a victim of your own success and
and and and the pressures that you know
suddenly befall you I mean you do move
forward I mean I feel like the second
movie got overshadowed by the whole
crowdfunding yeah
I stepped around at all of that yeah
which is weird I feel like if that
if somebody were to pursue that kind of
fundraising for their film now it would
it would be a very different response
than I don't know what happened then I
don't know I I definitely um
did not intend to become the face of
that
um
I was I've always been interested in
like new things and um and uh
you know Kevin Smith is the one who
turned me onto Myspace he's like you
gotta try this thing Myspace yeah so
awesome you can talk to your fans and
have a discourse with them and I'm like
really
so I've always been into like uh you
know and I wrote a Blog he's the one who
said you should write a blog you're a
writer you should you know wrestle back
in the day I was like writing he was the
first one to do a podcast too I mean
that guy's been at the front end of like
a lot of stuff before Myspace even I was
writing I had a on my zackgraph.com I
wrote a Blog I would write a blog and
he's the one who taught me all about
like interacting with your fans and
developing your fan base and it's so
cool if you're a writer you can have
like a daily conversation with your fans
I was like what
so I was kind of always interested in
the new thing in that particular thing
it just so it just so hit people the
wrong way and um you're right I I do
agree that it hurt the film badly and
and my My Hope Is that one day um you
know people will revisit Cameron Crowe
told me that and he's like he really
liked that movie and he was very
supportive of that movie and he said I
think one there's going to be a day I
don't know when it is he said but I
think there's gonna be a day where
people revisit that film and see it in a
different light well I can't remember
where I heard you tell the story but but
Larry David like smiled smiled once in a
while it's funny if you if you've made a
bunch of things anyone listening or or
anyone who's an artist and knows this
there are certain things you do that are
that people like and there's certain
things you do people don't but you you
have a certain soft spot in your heart
for things that didn't work that you go
that you go that just that just it it's
a nail in my heart a little bit Yeah
because that film was really personal
and and very hard to make and it was you
know it's about it was about the fear of
losing my father and my brother and I
wrote it together my brother Adam and I
wrote it together
every once in a while
someone will come up to me and they'll
be and of all things I've done and I've
done a lot when I'm 47 years old someone
will come up to me and say hey I just
want to say in the film we're talking
about it's called Wish I Was Here Wish I
Was Here was a really important film for
me and I and I and for me it's like that
they're they're complimenting my child
that that that's underappreciated
and so one of those was Larry David I
was in a restaurant and Larry David came
up to me and I was I was just totally
still and he said this movie uh wish I
was here you wrote that
no he was totally shocked and coming
from him who I love of all people
I was like yeah he goes
that's a really well written movie
so on behalf of my I mean come on right
like that was pretty cool yeah so I'm
hoping I'm hoping one day people see it
it's that it's I still have hope for it
it's that Seth Godin thing though like
you said earlier like what you put out
in the world shouldn't be for everybody
and you know to the extent that it
connects with a certain kind of person
like that's why you're doing it isn't
that what Gooden said he's like I'm not
making
Coke I'm not making Pepsi I'm not making
Doritos he said something like that like
like I'm trying to I'm trying to make
something that is uh
is is certainly most certainly not for
everyone but when you find the people
whether it's you or Larry David or or
the people that are are my fans um I'm
hopefully making something they can they
can relate to yeah
so you've done a ton of directing and
television to lasso and and and now
shrinking like working with Harrison
Ford and Jason Siegel which is super
cool but it's been a number of years
since you wrote directed your own film
right yeah um so I mean like why did
that take so long and and then kind of
maybe second to that like what is the
creative process is it just you know you
finally realize like you have a story to
tell and then there's a mad rush and you
get it done or like what does that look
like for you I battled it a lot I mean
I've been I I I I liked your
conversation about the war of Art and
getting your ass in the chair and
staring at the the blinking cursor you
just have to sit there it's so hard it's
so easy now to procrastinate and I'm um
I think the pandemic in this case really
made me run out of excuses Not only was
all of this
you know what it feels like when you
when you have something to say it's kind
of gurgling up it's kind of like
it's kind of like when you have to puke
for back of for lack of a better analogy
you used it's it's there and you know
you you know you have to sit at the
keyboard if you can just get your butt
in the chair to do it and I felt that
during the pandemic I felt like
I had something to say and I had I had
something I didn't know if it was going
to be good
um I knew I wanted to write it for
Florence because I I wanted I was in awe
of of her talent and um and so I just
sat down during the pandemic and it some
of it came fast and and easy and some of
it didn't
um
but that's what it is it's showing up
it's the war of art story it's yeah it's
putting your butt in the chair I can
procrastinate like like anybody and I I
look back and
um at years of procrastination I
directed a big Studio comedy um
um called going in style which was fun
you know it was fun to have a budget and
it was fun to direct you know Michael
Kane and Morgan Freeman and Alan Arkin
but but it wasn't and it was awesome I
would I would do a big fun Studio comedy
again it's just it wasn't um it
certainly wasn't me it wasn't uh
authentically uh something from my brain
and my heart yeah so Commerce and art I
find it very hard those two things right
I I don't want to say I find it hard
because that feels like it's it's it's
it's it's justifying it and speaking
into into existence and words have power
so I I just want to let me let me just
say that I have in the past done
everything I possibly can to
procrastinate and I Aspire
um going forward to be more disciplined
with putting my butt in the chair right
so when you get the call like hey we'd
love for you to come down and and uh and
direct this episode of Ted lasso or this
episode of shrinking you can arrive on
set and you get to work with like these
amazing actors and bring your lens your
specific unique creativity to that
process and and kind of nudge it in the
direction of your sensibility a little
bit but these are big machines yeah
um but they pay well and it's great and
you're like look at my career I'm doing
good but ultimately in the way that like
this podcast is a distraction from me
writing another book those things are
distractions from you being the writer
director who creates your own movies
from well I wouldn't use lasso and
shrinking as examples because first of
all they're very short commitments
relative uh you know it's basically a
six day shoot and a two-week prep for a
half hour episode of Television right
but that's that's three weeks of like I
don't really have to sit down and write
nobody I do find it very fulfilling I
don't wanna I'm not gonna just be a
director for hire first of all in the
case of lasso I was it was it was
episode two the episode biscuits it was
it was a really amazing opportunity to
help set the whole tone of the show um
so I was really honored that I got that
slot because it was episode two of Ted
lasso kind of introduces the audience to
like oh this is also going to break your
heart this show and then my episode of
shrinking which just aired um was also
sort of a seminal episode of season one
um
so for me they're they're I I really
love doing it I think that those can
co-exist it's really what I'm talking
about is you you know uh being on the
internet uh
um taking up 10 Hobbies uh doing things
that are anything to distract from what
I feel like I should be doing which is
writing films and and also keep in mind
when you write a film it's then a huge
process to try and get it made
and then then you shoot it and you cut
it and then it's then you have to wait
in this case I waited so long for it to
finally come out
um and it's finally coming out um
marched right because you finish this
thing yeah as you mentioned like a year
and a half ago or something yeah so this
is by my point is there's a lot of down
time
um that a yes my first priority I
believe uh if I'm if I'm being true to
myself should be should be writing
um but in terms of I don't want to go
Direct TV I don't believe in but in
terms of directing things I really truly
that are my that are my taste and that I
love I enjoy doing that yeah yeah yeah
so it it is creatively nourishing yeah
absolutely I mean I'm I'm I'm I'm
getting to make Harrison Ford uh be his
helping him be his hilarious self it's
crazy I've only watched the first
episode of shooting so you're you rep is
you're like episode eight or something
like that I'm episode eight but it's
really I gotta tell you I know I'm
biased but I'm only a little biased
because all I did was direct episode
eight I have no connection to the show
other than that and the show is
wonderful and I think you'll really like
it rich because it overlaps with a lot
of things that I think you're interested
in yeah yeah the mental health
discussion yeah um it is funny to see
Harrison Ford in a comedy he's hilarious
and what's crazy about that guy is that
I thought he was like this sort of you
know kind of
crusty Rascal who didn't really want to
work anymore and and was sort of sailing
off into the sunset and suddenly he's in
like everything guys like working more
than he's ever worked in his entire life
I think he loves working I think he
loves flying and he loves working he
loves flying but uh got to keep him out
of that plane and no one's going to keep
crashing on the golf courses well in his
defense you that's a glass half full
glass empty conversation I would say he
lost an engine in a plane and
successfully landed on a golf course
yeah I have a friend who's in you're a
pilot right so I have a friend a good
friend who's a pilot and he was flying
over the desert just a couple weeks ago
and had an engine failure and had to
land on I this is something that
happened yeah people make jokes for
Harrison Ford flying and I'm like the
guy landed a plane on a golf course uh
how about applaud him right
um but it is it must it must be you must
have
like those moments of is this real like
you know comparison it's crazy right
yeah especially when he says my name uh
uh that one's really trippy
because uh you know there's still people
I geek out about and when Harrison uh
you know first when I first got to know
him he he he didn't I don't think he
knew my name but then when he learned my
name and was calling me by my name it
was pretty it was the the little kid of
me was pretty good right so over the
years uh you've worked with De Niro
like Tommy Lee Jones right Michael Kane
like some of the some of the greats
right like what do you learn from like
what makes
those people so good are their
commonalities are there themes across
you know these people that we Revere for
this thing that they do that we can
learn from I think courage
real uh courage to
go all out without a net and and and and
and and and trust that the filmmaker is
gonna
be their safety net and and make sure
that it works I would say all of those
people
um
show up and are present and
go all out
um and sometimes it's too it's even even
them these Legends sometimes it's too
much um sometimes it's too little
sometimes it's not right that's one
thing I really learned is it's not
always
even the Geniuses it's not always right
but they're trying things and they're
playing and they're and they're
exploring and they're they're looking
for it just like a painter who keeps
painting over their their painting their
theirs they're hunting for it
um and um and with with real uh courage
um
so I think that's one thing I've I've
really taken from from the great Masters
I've had a chance to work with
and as the Director your job is just to
kind of
like calibrate those choices and kind of
get them in the line in in the in the
kind of Lane of the tone of the film
absolutely and it depends on the actors
some will I've worked with some I won't
say specific things but I worked with
one Legend who would do it who'd do one
take like right in the zone where I
wanted it and then he'd do one minuscule
and then he'd do one huge and you were
like what the [__] is that yeah he's
giving you choices but he's but he's not
as he gave me choices but he's kind of
playing himself and try I mean playing
with it himself to try and figure out
what's right and then there are other
great Masters who are like
there was one take
that was it I know I'm me that was great
right and you're like whoa whoa slow
down
yeah and then you as the Director have
to be able to like have a hard
conversation with somebody that yeah am
I Really Gonna like you know
step up to this absolutely do you know
how many times in a trailer rich I have
given myself pep talks in the in the in
the in the mirror of a trailer being
like you have to have balls right don't
like whether it's acting with De Niro I
was I was his co-star this movie hasn't
come out yet but it's it's uh it's a
comedy with De Niro and I'm his co-star
and I I was like this is the moment
you've been waiting for if you are a
wimp in this scene and don't go all out
and don't go toe-to-toe with Dinero you
know I had this scene where I'm
screaming at him and it's a it's a
comedy but it's I'm screaming at him uh
and the same thing with Morgan Freeman
it's like if Morgan's over it and and
you haven't gotten it you have to be
brave you have to not be a wimp you have
to not be intimidated
so I I definitely give myself these
these pep talks in the mirror in the
trailer
I can't even imagine that's wild man
when you're when you're sitting down to
write like what do you have a a routine
like okay these are the hours that I do
it or do you just strike when the
inspiration hits or you know how do you
how do you like I'm just thinking about
like the conversation that I had with
Robert McKee like everything's structure
so yeah do you have characters you start
with character do you start with plot
like how do you figure out these stories
I really want to take Robert McKee's
class by the way because I've never done
now but I know but there's there's a
video I listen to a Master Class by the
way after your he should do a master
class yeah but after your your podcast
with him I went on his site and there's
there is something in April maybe it's
pre-recorded I don't know but um
it's definitely uh virtual it's not like
but I really
even though he bummed me out a lot of
his stuff he said when he said film is
gonna be like ballet yeah I think I
texted you yeah like ballet I was like
rich I was like it's all up to you
though like if if a good person succeeds
then there's hope exactly well I'm
trying I hope people go I please don't
please don't make the theatrical
experience like ballet uh yeah that's
what Robert McKee said I am
but um I never I've never written like
that I think that that's very helpful to
a lot of people and I actually would
love to take a class because I've never
had a class like that and I think I
would get a lot out of it
um
but the it's not the way I write it all
because I have to see I kind of see the
way I write and I don't know if this is
unique to me or maybe other actor
writers write like this but I kind of
improvise the scenes out loud to myself
and then I write them as I go
so I kind of
get into character as each person in the
scene and then improvise the
conversation and then right as I go
so you're writing
dialogue from the get-go as opposed to
just conceptualizing like the Arc of a
story absolutely figuring out who what
who these people are and what they want
now in the macro I'll I'll have an idea
of I'm gonna start this thing and I
think I think the beginning is this and
the middle is this and then it'll it'll
get to there I have a I have a a a a a
GPS uh Point set if you will but I don't
do you know the ending not always
in Garden State I completely changed the
ending I mean Tarantino talks about that
he's like I just I just keep going and
that's what I do I figure out the ending
because I'm just following these people
and what they would do next I agree with
that school of thought from that great
master I I really kind of write a scene
and when it works
and again I have a vague idea where I'm
where I want to go but I when it works I
go well then what would happen
now I'm not always ready to write that
scene I might go oh what's probably
going to happen is uh their next
interior Cafe uh so and so and so and so
we're gonna have an argument I might
just write that and not be able to ready
to write that dialogue but then I'll go
and then what would happen
well she's gonna have to go confront her
father
I'm ready to write that one I haven't I
have some ideas for that so that one
I'll just just do a messy first you know
like throwing paint up on the canvas
it's not always all great but it's just
blah yourself getting it bad and getting
it up there because if you're not
sitting there doing that yeah you need
to get this stuff out so then all of a
sudden you're gonna write you know some
scenes in Garden State were just first
passes I never touched them again
because I was in a good Flow State and
something really meaningful came out
same thing with a good person
um but then of course of course there's
tons of scenes you you toss and you're
like I don't agree with Robert McKee
said he was saying that like 90 of it he
throws away I definitely don't do that
yeah
um what was interesting in in watching a
good person was that there were multiple
occasions where uh you know the
characters arrive at a certain point and
and there's a very kind of predictable
thing that you're primed to expect to
happen because you've seen it in movies
before right and then
there would be and then and then you
would make a different Choice like it
would be like oh this is where this is
this person's gonna do this and then
actually they do this other thing and
you're like oh wow
yeah okay we're gonna go in a different
we're gonna go somewhere new with this
thing that defies like that Trope well
that's the highest comment you give me
thank you I I think that you know even
as a writer you find yourself going
we've all seen so many movies right so
your brain starts to go yeah go here
and and you can't help but because we're
all conditioned from watching you know
47 years or whatever how old you are of
movies and there's certain things about
those tropes they're tropes because
there's aspects of them that work right
and yeah we were chatting before like
like when the person is sitting in the
AAA meeting like this is the moment for
exposition like you kind of need that or
like that serves a purpose right but
even in the end how do you do something
different with that but also without in
giving any spoilers the way I do it is
it might be a time a a share might be a
good moment for exposition
but it's also a moment to throw a
[__] loop at the audience and do a
reveal that they're certainly not
expecting yeah which is what happens
yeah there's there's a there's a bunch
of those in there
um but there are certain things that
that you know one thing about the Robert
McKee thing that I really do believe and
follow is that if you don't everything
you've ever watched at 30 minutes in
uh we enter the new world
because this is something that audiences
are completely conditioned to
um expect and if you can any movie
you're watching I mean obviously there's
exceptions but 99 of films that you
watch
at 30 minutes in we enter the new thing
so the first 30 minutes have been
setting up this is the way things are
this is the status quo
there's an inciting incident of the
world and then at 30 minutes in uh
especially a studio movie you can check
your watch it'll be 30 minutes you the
new thing Begins the exciting incident
is usually at like 10 minutes right
that's all that's that that's that that
can vary but one thing's for certain
um uh they they set off on the new thing
at 30 minutes right and that's an
example of something that if you go and
test a film and and you're not doing
that uh an audience won't know exactly
how to articulate it but they will say
like it felt slow and what they're
saying is you didn't start the new thing
at 30 minutes because everything I've
ever watched uh starts the new thing at
30. so you have this unconscious
expectation and if that's not met you
feel like oh this isn't working but you
don't even know like it's kind of like a
song really quick it's kind of like song
structure right you know when like like
it's gonna have a bridge it's gonna do
Verse Chorus first course first course
Bridge Verse Chorus or something like
that I'm not a songwriter so I don't
know but audiences like listeners know
that that's that's how most songs are
right and I think audiences know like
you know the hero's journey sure General
sense of the traditional Arc of a film
so yeah you have to you don't have to do
anything
um
but um but people are are conditioned to
be used to some rough form of that yeah
it's uh it's in saying like you don't
have to do that like it reminds me of
adaptation like the the sort of internal
tension and battle between the identical
twins which which of course it's a
multiple personality movie right like
he's at work Charlie Kaufman is at war
with himself because on the one hand and
McKee said this from his experience with
him he wants to be the artist but he
also wants to write the Blockbuster to
write the Blockbuster you have to follow
this sort of semi-formulaic thing where
you're meeting these expectations but
how do you express and explore art
within that and and it's those two
things butting up against each other and
when you find that right you know when
you can make those things work together
is when you create something you know
kind of amazing and unique yeah like
adaptation right
um that's
the the the the rare thing that is both
Artful
and accessible enough
for enough people to justify being in
the theater is The Sweet Spot right
right because so many of these um films
that are uh wardsy or or really Boutique
a niche audience they aren't necessarily
accessible to to enough people in 2023
to justify it being in the theatrical
experience yeah because um it's not
commercial enough yeah and it's a weird
conundrum because there's never been
more Avenues uh
uh and opportunities for filmmakers with
the streamers right there's just so much
content out there and so much creativity
that it's almost challenging as a
consumer like what do I watch next like
there's a lot of amazing [__] out there
and yet
um The Funnel towards like a theatrical
release has never been narrower it's
very very hard to get a theatric release
these days um particularly for something
that's not spectacle
um
and you I I learned a lot from um
another thing I got out of your Seth
Godin episode was his thing about you
have to give the audiences the why
why go to the theater for this you know
it's obvious when it's when it's
spectacle oh I want to see that on a big
screen
um
or if it's the whale with Brendan Fraser
the why is oh I'm excited for Brendan
Fraser's comeback and I want I root for
Brendan Fraser I want to go see that
um
and I think the the why for a good
person is that it's it's a it's not only
is it a really special thing to see
this extraordinary uh ingenue Florence
Pew go toe-to-toe with this Legend
Morgan Freeman but I really believe and
it's probably because of my love of of
the theater I still go to the theater in
New York all the time but there is
something that is very lost seeing
something emotional and immersive
um alone at home there's something
really beautiful about sharing that
experience with uh strangers in a room
and the laughter that happens the pin
drops silence that we experience the
sniffles we hear when there's an
emotional moment
um
I really I I still really long for that
experience and and I hope there's enough
people that that still do because um it
certainly is is rare and rarer these
days yeah well I I you know was not
prepared to
be emotional but it did I mean it cuts
close to home because of my own it's
very different from my story but it
explores certain terrain that I'm
familiar with and and you know I found
myself uh you know definitely emotional
watching it like and I think there is
something about that shared experience
that that is special and I think
the power in it not to kind of like harp
on this again but the power in it for me
is that yes there's an arc and there's a
three-act structure and all of that but
it doesn't like kind of it's not all
tied up in a nice little bow like it
really does show you like how gnarly and
messy and confusing this process of
grappling with grief and and you know
just just how [__] hard it is to be a
human and to come to terms with like
difficult emotions that all of us face
like we may not all be in the extreme
situation of of of being in a car
accident or you know having a an opioid
addiction or whatever it is but you know
you don't get out of this life alive and
we all face [__] crazy [__] and
obstacles like life doesn't go the way
that we plan it to go which is really
The Narrative of the show it's like
there's a there's kind of a beautiful
sort of trajectory lined up for these
characters and then everything goes
sideways goes Haywire and you know I
think most people like experience some
version of that in their lives and then
have to Grapple with how to how to you
know get right with themselves make
peace with it
um and and move forward in a healthy way
and and we do we don't do this elegantly
like this is not a clean process for for
anybody and I feel like the movie you
know appreciated that kind of
um
you know that Nuance of The Human
Condition well thank you very much and I
and I I I I I wanted
the audience to see themselves in the
characters like you just said very
articulately they're not they're not
necessarily going to have the horror of
a of a fatal car accident or perhaps
they don't know someone
um battling an opioid addiction but I
but I wrote it I had tended to write it
in such a way that and people would see
their own selves in the film whether
it's whatever their lowest point is the
film is about standing back up the film
is about the the drive and the hope
uh to continue
um after a really dark time not for you
that could be a divorce or it could be a
depression or it could be losing your
job or it could be whatever insert your
your low Point here it's really the film
is really a discussion
um of of the the human uh capability to
stand back up with Community with
friendship with love the ability to go
on and still have hope yeah you
mentioned uh you know beautifully but
you mentioned that you're not a
songwriter but you do have this you know
uncanny facility for for knowing exactly
the right needle draw but not exactly
the right moment right like you could
have had a a very successful career as a
music supervisor you know how to uh you
know kind of find the right music to uh
help tell your stories thank you I think
you know this is you've never been more
uh you know successfully
um
uh exemplified then in then in Garden
State like you basically like put the
Shins on the map this you create this
uh soundtrack album from that experience
you go you win a Grammy which is nuts
because like I'm sure it didn't even
occur to you
but anyway here's the best part of that
stuff here's the best part well there's
two parts of the story one is that I I I
I I idolize Quentin Tarantino and I only
met him like twice and the first time I
met him was after I I saw him at the
independent Spirit Awards after I'd
beaten him for the Grammy for original
soundtrack that's unbelievable and he
came up he comes up to me and he goes
you stole my [__] Grammy man
and I was like is he kidding is he
serious I love this man please love me
and he kind of smiled and he was he was
taking the piss as as the English said
but um but that was really surreal
because uh
the idea that I would win a trophy over
uh Quentin Tarantino was that like for
which I think it was the second Kill
Bill maybe so it wasn't pulp I mean I
mean but still that iconic but also you
know Garden State iconic for that for
that soundtrack The the story of that is
the ultimate um don't give up story ever
all those songs were songs I was
listening to at the time and songs I
loved and I put them in you know the
Avid which is the computer we edit on
um for my cut but there's not a single
person in town that didn't tell me
you're not going to get any of those
right it's for people that don't know
when you're cutting you do this temp
track and like these are the songs I'd
like to have we're never gonna get them
but like this is the vibe I'm going for
and what happens is you get temp love
you fall in love with that song but we
had no money we made that movie for two
and a half million dollars we didn't
have money to license all of these
incredible songs and I was told by
anyone and everyone
you will never get those songs you need
to start replacing them
and in the spirit of in the spirit of
being too young and not knowing what I
didn't know I was like no I'm going to
get them hmm I'm gonna get him it was
the I I didn't know it at the time but I
was manifesting
I was manifesting that there was no way
I was not going to get all of those
songs and I got every single one and
what to what do you account that like
how did that just not taking No
financial assistance persistence not
getting stuck not not going into the
fetal I'm sure I went to the fetal
position a couple times but
um not taking no for an answer
um
um I remember you know for example the
Paul Simon people only live in boy New
York it was one of the hardest ones to
get because it's probably it was
probably the biggest most expensive
in a normal in a normal world where
you're paying full rate probably the
most expensive song on the album
and it was a hell no hell no hell no
hell no and then I said what if we got
his manager
into a screening room and we just showed
him the moment how it's used
and they were like he's not going to
come just let's just try
and we the manager came with a few
people and they sat in the screening
room at CAA alone
and they watched the movie and at the
time the Paul Simon song came on I
looked over and they were all swiping
their eyes
and they said absolutely
we'll do it wow and then cut to that
whole summer Paul Simon was on tour and
he started playing Only Living Boy New
York and he never used to play it and he
was saying you know I never played this
song anymore but there's this movie that
came out called Garden State and he
started playing Only Living Boy New York
on tour
that's got to be such a crazy mind [__]
some and that happened with every track
it was like it was like it was like what
else is on you have Nick Drake there's
so many incredible songs on it and you
know a little by little the puzzle once
I got Coldplay and then once I got Nick
Drake and then once I got plus how many
other people that were smaller I just
started selling like oh well if the cool
kids are doing it we'll do it and right
and and we you know we figured out a
deal that was a that was that no one
ever thought they'd see money from but
was a back-end deal where you know in a
world where someone buys this soundtrack
you'd make money
thinking like haha that's never going to
happen but thank you for loaning us your
song at a rate we can afford and then
the thing goes on to be platinum and
they all made lots of money off of it do
did that lead to people contacting you
simply to like music supervise their
movies
I did have a deal that's probably the
only deal like this in the history of
deals but I I was I starred in a movie
called The Last Kiss yeah
um that I didn't direct some people
think I directed that movie but uh Tony
Goldman uh the actor director did Paul
Haggis right Paul Haggis wrote the
screenplay and I um
my deal was to Star and and uh do the
soundtrack that was my deal
that's yeah that's very unique I don't
know if anyone's ever had that deal
before but that was my deal uh-huh so
you're like I'll do it but I also I have
to do the musical well I was thrilled to
do it I really loved the script it was
it was an adaptation of a very very
popular uh Italian film called and
um I was thrilled to be in it and and
but I was so hot off the tales of Garden
State that they said hey will you also
do our soundtrack right I was like you
have the Golden Touch I was like music
yeah that's cool
um
so the Oscars are are tonight like what
how do you like when you when you cast
your Gaze on you know the movies that
are being feted and the kind of movies
that are getting made like how do you
think about the state of Hollywood and
is it is it is it headed towards that
ballet situation that McKee talked about
I think it's it's it's it's
um the jury's still out
it really changes it's really we are
watching it all change before our eyes
in the spirit of Seth Godin uh audiences
need a story as to why a particular film
is worth making the Trek to the theater
cinephiles of course there's a group of
cinephiles who will always go
those are the people like the people who
buy vinyl to to listen to music
um
but what is the story that beyond beyond
just the category of oh it's a giant
spectacle you need to see it on the big
screen
um
the jury is still out on on on whether
whether films will still be released
theatrically that are not in that
category
and I think the that the jury is out on
an explanation as to why the general
public the public at large should care
about this art form
yeah and I think it becomes harder for
that person to care when the choices
they're being offered are are just
amusement park rides versus you know
kind of challenging
this is why you're here today like I am
I'm doing help me help you a good person
here a good person March 24th there you
go there you go but at the same time
like
I'm on these streamers and I'm like
seeing I just I'm so nourished by you
know all different kinds of Storytelling
formats that aren't necessarily the kind
you know like like the the sort of
Advent of the limited series like I'm
like like watching like I don't know
crime stories set in Iceland and like
all this stuff I know but it's a
separate experience it is that's a
different one I want to savor and what I
hope Mr McKee is wrong about it becoming
ballet is that there is
I I I just a very sacred experience of
going into a theatrical house and
sitting with strangers and watching a
piece of art and also this societal
agreement for most people that we turn
off our phones
for two hours and immerse ourselves in a
story and at home we're pausing and
we're checking our phone and we're
saying did you feed the dog and all of
this stuff that is not immersing
yourself in a story now again I'm a
theater lover and goer so I I had that
experience with Live Theater which is
which is for the community of people
that are into that we know that but I I
for the Cinematic experience I pray that
that doesn't go away because I find it
um very very special and and um and and
not something that's akin to watching
your favorite streaming program it is
fully immersive
and there's something magical about
being around
um other people experiencing the same
thing yeah Amen to that but we need more
good movies in the pipeline I'm doing
all I can I know you are I know you are
um it's funny because I when I was you I
the movie's not out so I got like a link
to see a screener and and uh and then in
the middle like I I snapped a little
photo and I sent it to you and you're
like Focus what are you doing like don't
do you're being a guy I know it's like
being the guy I felt terrible right
you're being the guy who's on his phone
yeah but you know why
you were at home yes yeah I wouldn't
have done that in a theater of course
you wouldn't know and um and and you're
and I just I submit you're going to get
way more lost in the theater into a
story I agree
um for for the aspiring writer Creator
filmmaker who who's listening to this
um what is the you know what is the the
kind of inspiration or or the advice
that you can give that person who's
embarking upon a career or thinking
about
um exploring storytelling as a
as a lifestyle well a famous writer I
forgot who it is said uh being a writer
is signing up to have homework for the
rest of your life
yeah um is that Lawrence casner I think
it's Lauren's Castle yeah which I think
is very accurate we're having a podcast
it's pretty good for having homework all
the time
but a podcast is communal yeah that's
true a podcast you have friends you have
crew members you have this beautiful
Studio
uh writing and sitting alone at a
blinking cursor telling yourself you
suck
um it's hard that's why I would tell
people I I won't be as um try and scare
anyone away from it
um but know that it's
that I'm this deep into it and I battle
procrastination I battle working
so I would say develop very early on I
mean you've had some of these amazing
people on your podcast uh what's the
name of the the guy who wrote War of art
Stephen pressfield yes the impress field
and and um and the like
um you know you have to develop a system
very early on
something I never did that that is
Fail-Safe for you working and producing
content and that is in in 2023 that is
very much turning off your Wi-Fi and
getting your phone out of the room
um there are so many distractions
um and then I believe with with Mr
pressfield it's about putting your butt
in the chair and not being afraid to not
know what it is today but getting in the
chair and showing up mm-hmm
um
but it's it's
like running with an elephant on your
back if you're if you're trying to do it
with your phone in your hand
um are you able to take that sensibility
that energy and get right back into it
yeah this time like as soon as you lock
it you're on to the next for the first
time in my life I'm I'm I'm like halfway
through a new screenplay now but that's
with a lot of
uh that's with maturity and also uh
really coaching myself and working with
people
um my therapist in particular
um uh who's a cognitive behaviorist was
just very very valuable to me of
developing systems that um support you
not failing
um so what would be an example of that
uh making commitments to produce pages
to people
um even he I mean I have I have uh you
know people I work with in terms of like
who I who I get thoughts on my writing
but even my therapist uh even if he uh
is not going to read them he's just
external he will say like
um so
um how many pages are you going to send
me by by Friday so that's just one
example of a system that's in place I'm
I I'm I'm committed to turning in work
um
I have this light board thing I think I
sent you a link to it that really helps
me um it's a it's just this I mean you
can literally do this with a paper
calendar and and do stickers on it like
you when you're potty training your kid
uh it's a matter of like um giving
yourself uh a going for a streak that is
to say you only get a sticker or or you
light the thing up my therapist actually
said you can do it with a light he's
with his clients have done it with a
light bright before but the point is
you're only
you want to go for a streak just like I
know people who are doing uh or who are
in a program and we're in going for
sobriety want to streak uh it is it is
how many days can I write in a row or
how many how many how many days will I
commit to someone whether it be my
partner or myself
or whomever your therapist that I will
write Monday through Friday for a
minimum of four hours a day and um and
when I don't I've I've I've I've I've
dropped my streak and there's something
about a streak that's very powerful yeah
it's it's an interesting thing like how
reptilian the human brain is like but
momentum is real and once you Bank a few
days and you got a little bit of energy
behind it and you're gonna put that
little light bulb in the thing like
you're like that's enough you know I was
telling you to get you to get keep going
I was telling you this uh when we met
that I I was working on taking a break
from alcohol and that I and uh I found
that if I printed a paper calendar
and literally I got I ordered stickers
on Amazon
and I would just when I didn't drink
that day I would put a sticker on the on
the calendar and
it worked for me I I was like I'm not
gonna not get my mind I gotta get my
sticker I want my [__] sticker
I don't even want this glass of wine I
want my sticker
oh my God it's like I don't know whether
to be encouraged by that or just think
humanity is doomed you know well I think
it's um I don't know you say it's
reptilian um but I think
um I don't know I I guess my my
therapist says it best is that there's a
lot of power in a streak yeah I know
that that's for sure that there's it's
empowering to say I'm not gonna [__] up
now yeah you got to respect the momentum
yeah and protect it you know and create
boundaries around it I love that your
episode um I forgot the name of the guy
who um
did um um a one year no beer
oh Andy ramage yeah yeah that was an
amazing episode so that that was a lot
of things he said too with in in the in
the with regard to alcohol and
you know finding that space for for
people that don't necessarily think they
need uh to work a program
um I think they can probably do it on
their own
um but but also want to want to rethink
their attitudes towards alcohol
consumption uh I thought that was
you know he talks about streaks and
that's the whole idea behind it is like
do 28 days you know do 90 days and uh I
found that incredibly empowering yeah he
you you can always go back to what you
were doing before and I think what's
cool about that movement
um that that Andy helped create is like
you said there's a lot of people out
there that wouldn't classify themselves
as alcoholics but you know get to a
certain age like hey do I really need to
be hungover today like why do I you know
go out and binge every other weekend or
whatever it is
um but when you're in a culture where
that's just the thing that you do it can
be difficult for social reasons to
opt out of that and to have like a
community of people to support you in
finding a different way
um and then and then you know uh uh
experiencing what it's like to be
alcohol free for perhaps the first time
and and seeing how much better you feel
and how I'm more present you are in your
life and how more productive you are I'm
doing it I will be honest and tell you
that I'm doing it um
I
I'm taking on his challenge nice and um
and um I have you to thank man I really
I really thank you so much for for
bringing I'm sure there's other people
listening and if you haven't you have to
go listen to that episode
um I never felt I never saw anything in
my life that spoke so directly
to me and my relationship with alcohol
because I never felt like
I would I would certainly uh go to AAA
if I if I felt I needed to and and and
maybe we'll make that decision one day
but I just thought that episode was so
and his work is so genius because it it
it hits a sliver of the population that
hadn't necessarily been addressed before
which is
like why do I why am I doing this habit
and and for people that do have the
power to just to to not work a program
and just try and say no what would my
life be like without it
um
so that was very very very
powerful to me and um I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm I'm
aiming to go six months and see what
happens but I uh I feel [__] great
that's awesome man well you're here
today for me to help you get the word
out about your movie but I feel like I'm
getting more out of this from you
promoting no I'm promoting your show
recruiting your joke of like uh yeah I
just got back from the United Kingdom
promoting your podcast like well I
wasn't there okay and I was on the Chris
Evans show and uh and and we and I
didn't even know that he knew you but we
started talking about you know anyway I
I know I I appreciate it man I've said
enough Rich yeah but I just but you have
you have made a big difference in my
life and and and I can imagine for so
many people listening uh they feel the
same way well it's incredible uh to hear
that and I'm working on just receiving
and yeah thank you
um but it is amazing uh and and a bit
surreal as somebody who who has followed
your work for a very long time and and
has a ton of respect for
um you know the the art that you share
with the world and uh I couldn't you
know be more excited about this new
movie it like I said to you it's it's
beautifully rendered and I think
everybody should go out out and check it
out yes thank you I'm excited
for you to have that experience of of
having a movie back in the theaters
after a very long time thank you it's a
pretty cool and very special experience
and I hope that you can
um navigate it with presence and with
gratitude and not get caught up in all
those externalities that you can't
control because irrespective of how it
does or doesn't do
um you should be very proud of what you
created thank you Richard yeah and uh it
was a pleasure thank you today and you
know yeah man this was super cool if
people wanna um we should we should
probably tell people how to how to find
tickets and all that kind of stuff right
Fandango is the most popular one you can
see you can find tickets on Fandango and
just in the US or is it internet
um in the UK and uh us all right cool so
check it out you can get tickets on
Fandango if you're in the United States
or in the UK and uh first weekend super
important yeah gotta get out there right
away I can't wait around please check it
out this weekend everybody I really
appreciate it all right cheers thanks
thanks Zach
[Music]
thank you